and that's why you do have to respect
people in Israel that are willing to go
back and
fight you know what I mean nobody's in
this country is willing to make that
type of set you think Chrissy Tan's
gonna get in the parag
glider is Chrissy Teegan in the
paraglider she's just paragliding it's
not gonna
happen go to the call center we'll tell
you when we need you when we need you
you're going to have to keep calling
elderly people with dementia you get
their credit card numbers of Social
Security you take their house you steal
it from them then you give it to someone
else and that person buys it they pay
way too much for it then they're [__]
you keep calling them you get them
second mortgages and credit cards you
mire them in debt you put them you put
them on the wheel put them on the
wheel go to the call center that's where
we need you sign the letter because if
you're not working in the call center
you you're signing the letter you're on
the Upper Crust you're either in a call
center like a little rat with your head
on the phone going hello is this Mrs
matui hey it's Barry how are you doing
can I tell you about a program we have
to consolidate you like you're either
that or you're sitting at home in Malibu
and you're like can you read the letter
to me
Francis what does it say well sign it we
must we must bring an end to this hurt
this hurt is horrible we must bring an
end why does she do the avocado like
that I'm Bri I'm not even British but I
talk like this because I'm very rich in
America many women in America will start
to talk like this even though they're
not British um but that's what it is and
that's why that's why I think it's an
attitude adjustment it's an attitude
adjustment attitude adjustment this is
not seen as a neag it's Halloween it's
fun it's sexy time everybody's going to
be fine or we won't but the point is
this stop looking at all this negatively
this is kind of our
thing this is kind of our thing just
sign the letter or go to the call center
it's all going to be
okay don't
start trying right now at this point in
your life to have
honor do you know why they tell people
like in their 70s or 80s to not quit
smoking because at a certain point you
just the bile that comes out of your
system at the end isn't worth it because
it's just black Gunk you cough up and
stuff you know basically it's just like
maybe they'll tell you to cut down but
it is what the [__] it is what are you
gonna do quit smoking at
80 and do be a gymnast it's that's you
start doing [__] marathons that's not
what it is at the end the bile the gunk
the poison that you cough up out of your
body kills it if you quit smoking so you
can't okay so at the end of the
Empire if you discover
honor you better be very careful how you
do it because it's going to cause you to
cough up a lot of
bile and it might just kill you so be
very
careful go to the call center get on the
phone sign the letter have a cup of
coffee nod to the person in Starbucks
very sad wish it was better sorry about
that brighter days ahead let's hope
everybody gets their [__] thinking
cap on cooler heads prevail what a great
saying how American I hope cooler heads
prevail go to the backyard have a
cocktail you're not dead yet cooler
heads
prevail tell your kids that everything's
fine because as of now it is don't start
going crazy we don't need a bunch of
Colonel curtes running around that's not
your job your job job is not to lead
some type of
sectarian Revolution here your job is to
come up with 10 five to 10 phrases you
repeat at nauseum while you drink your
flavored coffee Amaretto French vanilla
hazelnut is that called that's a creamer
called Italian holiday cookie
ooh terrible times hope cooler heads
prevail
yeah hope things don't spin out of
control things over there are tough come
up with the phrases you repeat them at
nauseum you get in your car you get in
your car it'll be okay I promise you
nobody's going to knock on your door and
ask you to make the great sacrifice it's
not the way that you have been built we
have not engineered this
experiment um around the idea of
selfless
can we say that is it fair to say that
kids is it fair to say that we've not
engineered the American experiment
around
selflessness that's not what we're about
is it no we are about us your stance in
everything is you cooler heads prevail
have a cup of
coffee my friend's mother she knew
someone over there God so tough hits
close to home that's a good one go hits
close to home hits close to home cooler
heads hopefully cooler heads prevail